is the jonco underground podcast number
75 sitting here with Echo Charles so
here's something I sent out on the
social media
platform sure Twitter you heard of
Twitter sure no that's right you got
hacked
sure Elon Musk right that's Twitter yeah
yeah here's what I sent out Twitter
Twitter isn't good for everyone if it
makes you angry or frustrated you
shouldn't spend time on it if it allows
you to see other people's perspectives
so you can understand the world better
or you can share some information with
other people that that other people
might not have that's good enjoy
no big deal
now there's a little bit of
something a little bit antithetical
about me saying that because if you've
got something that's bothering you
shouldn't you confront it
you know what I'm saying it's kind of
stretch maybe it's a stretch to say that
but there's a reason why I said it
because look there's a person there's a
personality type
anxiety gets to them you ever have
anxiety no
some people they get anxiety hits them
yeah it's a problem there's such a thing
as an anxiety attack yeah where people
have to like stop what they're doing
right yeah well I hear it's like a heart
attack like they think they're dying
anxiety attack so that's a person that
can have that going on yeah
um
there's personalities that can get angry
over things that they shouldn't get
angry about that's who I'm talking about
right now right different personalities
now there's benefits to social media for
sure
for sure there's benefits you can like I
said you can hear other people's
perspectives you can learn about things
you can link to a good article that you
could get some good information from you
can see other people's perspectives like
there's some we've gotten connected
to a lot of really cool people that have
come on the podcast that connected
through the social media and I would say
primarily Twitter most of the time
all those things are good but let's face
it hey look we know if you're in the
algae here the algorithm is grabbing you
and you're just wasting time on it we
know that's bad
but if you're getting angry
that's not good and you shouldn't spend
time on it now here's where you know
people are talking about Detachment yeah
I talk about Detachment obviously yeah
and then people say how do you do it and
I explain how to do it and then how can
you practice it you if if Twitter or
social media makes you mad you could
legitimately use it
to practice Detachment you legitimately
use it to practice detachment
so
go on your social media
if you're so inclined you want to
practice some Detachment go on there and
go and look at some people that you
totally and vehemently disagree with
um
and read what they wrote and watch the
video that they posted
and then be like okay
how's this like it's kind of a good
environment to do it in because you're
by yourself you can you can actually
monitor your emotions right you're going
You're like you're not confronting
anyone yeah it's not real but have you
ever read something on social media that
made you get a little bit mad
I feel like yeah I feel like I have I
can't remember anything it's articulate
but
if it's about me yeah about a derogatory
comment on a YouTube channel on a
YouTube video about you
no not that made me mad never I don't
know probably but I can't remember
anything specific no what about some
political belief that someone threw out
there knewer you get dissed get mad I
got and yeah like man not mad for me
come on mad but I got like annoyed
there's a guy that says stuff in the way
he says it is super smarmy kind of like
you're so dumb for not believing this
you know like that's the attitude and
that's super annoying for sure okay so
you're probably in a pretty good place
actually I think I feel like you don't
need to practice your Detachment you're
pretty emotionally detached and I can
all spun up
this is an opportunity for people that
might get spun up and I'm gonna tell you
if you're the type of person that gets
spun up on social media you're probably
getting spun up while driving you're
probably getting spun up while your wife
is talking to you you're probably
getting spun off by your kids you're
probably getting spun up by uh somebody
in the grocery store you see what I'm
saying yeah
am I wrong I don't think you're wrong
now so I'm saying you could legitimately
go
you're in a detached position a little
bit because you're just looking at your
phone right yeah if you can't detach
while you're looking at your phone it's
a good place to practice
and look at something that really makes
you mad and say oh that's an interesting
perspective they have yeah that's that's
interesting yeah and then read another
one and say oh I'm glad I understand
them better now
and if you can't
that you can you can if you can make
progress over time it's going to be
helpful for you now listen if it just
makes you mad don't do it if you're
getting so mad
first of all you should reflect on that
if you're getting mad at a bot that's my
immediate thought anybody that's saying
something that's really bothersome I'm
thinking that's a bot
right it's not even a human being
it's a programmed AI yeah
yeah you say that a lot but I don't know
a bot yeah
I don't know anything about bots so the
only bots I know are the ones hacking my
account and
doing doing like everyone else Echo
Charles got hacked they took his Twitter
and you did some dumb honestly I don't
know I'm trying to be just disrespectful
with this it's a lot it was a lapse of
judgment you did some dumb you like
clicked out of Twitter and then it said
to get back to Twitter enter your
password I mean that's ignorant right
yeah yeah big time so don't do anything
dumb if you do
like Echo did then
well Echo lost everybody on he lost all
his followers yep that was bad but he's
back now Echo Charles at Echo Charles so
listen all I'm saying is people ask for
a place to try to detach and if you're
getting mad at social media you're
probably one of those people that needs
to practice it yeah so practice it if it
drives you crazy get off of it forget it
maybe go on once a month
and rehearse and practice Detachment but
if you're the type of person that's
going full Karen
you know what I'm saying yes I do I do
know what you're saying and Karen can go
in any direction right is that right or
is Karen a specific is Karen uh uh right
wing or left wing
uh no no no neither right it's just
Karen yeah so
if you feel like maybe you're a Karen
I think I tried I was trying to figure
out what the male Karen is called and
you know what I figured it out
milk here I thought there was like a
name I think there might be but I forget
what it is
my prices have done better research on
the subject anyways I think a male Karen
is called Karen you're still Karen yeah
uh you're you're it's a it's a
non-gender specific yeah I think that's
viable because if if I call you a caring
you know exactly what I'm saying exactly
like you're just an entitled complainer
yeah essentially you could be
complaining about anything yeah if you
think you need to talk about me
to the manager
true all right so it's legit training
just throwing it out there listen please
don't let the social media ruin your
life
don't let it waste your time get
positive benefits out of it
that's all I'm saying try it there you
go that's my statement for today uh so I
had that today where where and you
talked me out of it by the way oh you
didn't know you talked me out of it but
I was listening to your episode with
huberman okay and you were on the part
where you're talking you know and you
say this a lot where the storm cloud
right yeah you know just it's kind of it
is a detaching basically
um but it's it's essentially yes just
explain that if you can't detach you
can't see what's outside that storm
cloud you're just in the storm cloud
yeah as soon as you detach take a step
back you can get out of the storm cloud
you go oh I see myself in there and I
need to walk in this direction I'll be
out of it okay cool so yes so and then
so I was getting anxiety so yes and
doing getting the way I see it there's
like different kind people have anxiety
like as I think it's called like chronic
and anxiety versus like acute anxiety or
something like this from what I
understand so I don't have that but um
so I was doing squats today while I'm
listening to the episode yeah anxiety
can come with squats 100
so I don't know if you ever have this
but
like squats every once in a while I'll
have like a nightmare like it's like a
Daydream
of like all my tendons and like all my
tendons and my legs are gonna snap oh I
haven't had that night that's horrible
yeah it is horrible
of course it never happens but
like I'll have every once in a while
once in a great while
so today for I don't even know why it
wasn't even that heavy but it was it
like hit me that idea hit me right when
you guys are talking about that just
like happenstance you didn't cause it or
not like that and I'm like and it got to
me so bad that I was like I don't think
I'm gonna do these squats today like I'm
I think I might like get jammed up today
real bad I think my Patel attendants are
gonna snap on this spot right it wasn't
even that heavy so nonetheless and it
was the kind whereas you know when you
you
get anxiety like you start to like
kind of faint a little bit like you feel
like kind of faint I was feeling kind of
faint I don't know that it hasn't
happened to me honestly that's why it's
a little bit tough to relate yeah on
this I know the feeling of like squats
suck I know the feeling of thinking to
myself I don't even know if I want to be
strong yeah this next set is gonna suck
so bad that maybe I just should be
weaker but I'm just accepted that's not
anxiety though that's like um this is
mental weakness yeah like you got
confronted with a mental like
confrontation and it kind of got had you
on the road that's what it is yeah and
that's way easier to get past in my
opinion than this this is almost like
almost like you ever you ever felt
claustrophobia before no you never felt
possible before
okay
not really okay I I will say this when I
see someone in a cave diving and they're
all G they're all squeezing through a
space yeah
I think to myself that does not look fun
look
feeling claustrophobia is similar to the
anxiety oh and my thing I'm literally
referencing what happened to me today
where it was like I'm on this like weird
slippery slope and all I got to do is
stop slit just stop just stop moving or
stop slippery it's like a real like easy
switch not easy but a real simple switch
to switch but it's just you got to focus
on switching it it's like that kind of a
feeling and I was like man I can't
switch it I'm like going deeper into
this thing like
like I might die even I don't know it
was weird and
it's so dumb but meanwhile you're
talking in in the ear where you're
talking about the storm cloud and it's
like all you got to do is take one step
out of the side of the storm cloud you
see what everyone else has seen you're
like oh my gosh that's like way
like everyone outside the stone clock
and be like hey this girl's not worth
your
downfall right now bro or hey you need
to stop drinking bro or hey you need to
quit that job or whatever the case may
be yeah and to me it was bruh first off
that's not even heavy
didn't wait a million times on my way up
to like heavyweight it's not heavy
and in the history of history of squats
I don't think I've ever really injured I
injured my back before but I can't even
got it ever in squats and I used to get
my squad on anyway
so that's what I saw after I finally did
flip the switch I'm like what am I even
doing and then I go and I do it it's
like super easy no stiffness no nothing
so like oh what am I even doing but it
did get me for a little bit all right so
you do get anxiety
that was the first time that I got
anything that felt like that like I
couldn't escape it like it was so
unreasonable yourself maybe this is like
a legit warning yes yeah oh [__] yeah
that was that was part of the whole gig
man I was like this is a sign straight
spreads growing up these two girls they
were Twins and
oh there was some situation they were
coming on a train or getting on a train
to visit or something
and they were like they called This is
back in the day we're talking landlines
you know they called on the phone
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen
go to Jocko underground.com And
subscribe and we're doing this to
mitigate our Reliance on external
platforms so we are not subject to their
control and we're doing it so we can
give you more control more interaction
more direct connections better
Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it cost eight
dollars and 18 cents a month and if you
can't afford to support us we can still
support you just email assistance Jocko
underground.com and we'll get you taken
care of until then we
you mobilized
Underground